[Music]
hi
i'm tanya rapley entrepreneur and
financial educator
and i can say in all honesty i've never
seen
anything like this my income has been
disrupted okay my daughter's at home now
all day every day we essentially lost a
third of our
income and we don't really know when
it's coming back
which is why we brought together this
digital community a group from around
the country
with bank of america specialists for a
series of
open and honest conversations how do i
make credit
work for me don't get overwhelmed by the
numbers
let me see if i can bring the bill down
at a different clip we have tools to
help you
understand contribution levels but if
you fall in love with the process itself
those sacrifices will pay off in the
long run
this is better money habits money talks
brought to you by bank of america all
right so this is going to be a money
conversation like you guys probably have
never had before
we're gonna pair you with specialists
from bank of america
and i would love to learn more about you
rachel so yeah i've i've uh had to take
a huge
shift i went from teaching in a
classroom to teaching
on my computer i went from working five
days a week to my only stable encompass
is once a week now which is
scary coronavirus is a lot of people's
rainy day and their big emergency but
for me um
i was in a traumatic car accident of
january 2019
i was rear-ended on the freeway my car
flipped over onto its side
not only do i have the debt i had before
i have medical debt on top of that
and it feels really overwhelming it's
like running a marathon and not knowing
where the finish line is
yeah i've been speaking with a lot of
people who are dealing with debt it
feels like that so we were like coming
up with a great financial plan
life was looking great and then the
pandemic hit my main job
as a design engineer i was asked to take
a pay cut and then i lost my second job
as a performer inside the city during
nights
we weren't able to do the show and so i
lost a second
income entirely as a result of it me and
my fiance
were just talking about this last night
weddings are not
cheap we don't know if the wedding is
gonna happen
anytime soon as our income got disrupted
yeah we definitely have to look at
expenses that just like come out that
you don't even realize
i just want to shout out my fiance
because she was like i'm not buying any
new clothes
for at least a month yeah she just
started going on thrift sites
why do i want to pay full price for
something when i might be able to get a
deal
and i thought that was like really sad
my landlord
knows that we're both looking for
full-time work and so she's given us a
laundry list of things to do and she
says just count your hours i'll pay you
25
an hour and just take it out of rent we
did 400 worth of work for her
before we even moved in so we were able
to take that out of
just the first month's rent that's
amazing
so we decided to plant a garden
and we almost have to grocery spending
we're both chefs
we are both
and make food we had just bought our new
house and then
we lost kind of like a third of the
income stream coming in
so we do all this budgeting beforehand
and you can never really budget for the
unexpected really we're just trying to
find the little hacks to save money
we actually learned how to can as well
we have sauces
and vegetables and fruit compotes
and one day we will eat them
right we're gonna have to we have so
much of it now meal prep
and meal planning has been the very
thing that i think
changed my budget so something really
cool that has happened for us during
covid
is that my daughter and i got to move
into our own space together our own
apartment
um we have never been able to live on
our own because i couldn't do it
financially on my own
a year and a half ago i was living
paycheck to paycheck like there were
times where
i had to ask friends for gas money and
here we are now a year later
and i'm really excited to change our
family tree
and break those generational curses and
that
is such a fun and exciting thing to look
forward to for the future for me and my
daughter
yes kudos so much good has happened
i know that chelsea is a new mom hi i'm
chelsea
i live in northeast ohio so i did not
have any maternity leave
nor did i qualify for fmla and my
husband did not have any paternity leave
because both of us are working from home
my husband was able to
see our son way more than
if he was at work eight hours a day
this is where we used to eat dinner
now it's been our workstation both of
our
parents are close to us um and there
have been times in which we have asked
them to come over and babysit so we
could clean our house
so just taking advantage of
people who want to help and not being
afraid
to ask for that help each of you have
different goals that you're working
towards or different things that you
like
a little more insight on how to navigate
during this time
and so what we'll be doing is you'll
pair up with a bank specialist
to answer any questions that you have
and really get a plan of action
and then from there we will reconvene
so does that sound good to you
amanda and andrew you were in for a
treat we have joining
us our bank of america specialist
anthony denello
give andy a little rundown of what your
pressing questions
are we essentially lost a third of our
income
and it was right around the time we
bought this house at this point we
kind of normalized and kind of
stabilized a little
bit but we really had to sit down and
think about what the wants versus the
needs were and i think the first most
important thing is what are
the monthly expenses that you have what
are the bills that you have
that you can count on having to be
responsible for every month
that should be your floor now let's see
what money we have left over
and what is our budget going to be for
the month
he actually helped me write my first
budget in an excel spreadsheet i'm glad
there's an excel wizard in the house
that always helps to have an honest
mistake or two will happen along the way
so it's very important that you set up
alerts i actually have an alert on my
phone for every single time
a debit card is swiped i get a text
message it's a good idea
i like the alert thing so that both of
us know that the spending would be
happening
but to keep the communication open
you know it really helps establish
checks and balances because
then like you're accountable to someone
other than yourself for
like how you're spending i do also have
a bank of america credit card which
i love because the system they have on
the back end is really useful for money
management the alerts
is something i do have set up online and
that's just good to know when
whenever your card's being used or
whenever your budget's close to being
exceeded even if it's like 14
under you know it feels good that you're
within your means of what you're trying
to do that month
you're gonna probably say okay uh our
goal would be to save
this much this month i would have two
numbers in mind
and i would really strive for that
stretch goal and really challenge
yourselves because i think you would be
surprised what you're capable of
it's like the chinese food last night we
are
close to our eating out budget for the
month
but last night i was craving chinese
food and he looks at me he goes we're
close to the budget we can't get it so
we have leftovers
yeah you guys are great it was good
leftovers i'm glad we did it
there's a lot of value right and
starting to look at long term
and how much overall you could save when
consolidating debt
what type of debt is it how much do i
owe how much is your minimum monthly
payment
and then what is your interest rate for
me it's my favorite spreadsheet that's
the one where like
things are getting done i think that's a
pretty cool idea i never really thought
honestly
of doing anything like that it allows
you to see like what your most
expensive debt is or what's the smallest
balance it allows you to focus your game
plan
some people say start with the biggest
balance first because the more you can
knock that down the better
personally i like to start with the
smallest ones
first that smaller amount you could pay
off quickly
it feels good when you get one paid off
and then you have that extra money to go
towards the other
payments that you have until now i
didn't really think of it as a bunch of
small pieces i kind of just think of it
as this big wall
if we look more at it more of it as like
a bunch of bricks on a wall and you're
just taking pieces out one at a time i
think it's going to seem
manageable and it will encourage you to
continue to do
more and more the first thing we're
going to do is make a spreadsheet with
our that's an interest
so like i'm going to now it's not a date
night thing
the money
[Music]
when trying to stick to a budget stretch
goals can be highly motivating
organize all of your debt by balance
amount and interest rate to help
determine the best
debt reduction strategy for you
[Music]
and so chelsea i know that you're in
good hands we have our bank specialist
marcella gallego i don't think there's
anyone
more perfect to assist you with your
goals so we may need to look into some
child care
and so wondering some different ways
that we can budget for that
what worked for me best when i was doing
this exercise
was i did a decision three writing down
if i had to
go with a nanny what exactly do i want
if i want to do daycare what type of
taker
and then budget and find out how much it
will cost you
and we landed on a hybrid option we do
daycare in the mornings and grandma
comes in the afternoons i never thought
about
that split it allows her to be social
and have fun
but in the afternoons he's with grandma
which is great and um
and it's a little bit cheaper how do i
set up a bank account for my son it is a
lot simpler than you think
you have a minor account which will be
joined
with you or you can open an account
for them they are the owner but you are
the custodial
you just go to the bank with their
social security number and
open the account voila once daniel
is becoming a teenager now you can open
a checking account with him
so you can teach him how to use his
money
long term college is very important to
us
while we don't know what the education
system is going to look like in 18 years
or even if he gets a full ride and all
of a sudden doesn't need
that money so we don't necessarily want
to put money into a pocket that we can't
ever get out 34 usually comes from
financial aid
and parents are usually responsible for
29 to 30 percent of the bill
don't get overwhelmed by the numbers
time is on your side
in the sense that you have 18 years and
small amounts
consistently over that period make
a huge difference it sounds to me like
you
need flexible options and
it might be a combination of things you
can have
savings account and a college plan
that perhaps has some uh tax advantages
to it okay
so you could do a combination of both
don't feel
that you have to get married with one or
the other because
you don't we did buy our house about
three and a half years ago
we've been watching the mortgage rates
just plummet and even though we
got a good rate when we originally
signed the paperwork does it make sense
to refinance
refinancing is basically doing a whole
new loan
for your house all over again so when
you first purchase your home there were
some closing costs associated with
processing that loan
if you are going to save let's say 200
but the closing cost associated with
refinancing the home at five thousand
dollars if you are not going to stay for
at least 25 months
then you're not saving any money divide
the closing costs
by the savings that you will obtain
and that tells you how long you will
have to be in the property for that to
be
a cost effective decision that easy math
problem makes so much sense
and makes it a lot more black and white
considering refinancing factor closing
costs and how long you plan to own your
home
into the decision a decision tree is a
helpful tool for making financial
decisions
like selecting child care options
[Music]
and andre um is joining us amid andre
is a better money habits champion he is
one of the bank of america specialists
and so i met
let us know exactly what you hope to
glean from these sessions once
coronavirus hit my primary job
asked us to take a 20 pay cut
and then my second job lost that income
completely
i did notice that you're an actor right
so and you have taught before
so is there a possibility that you could
maybe do some online acting classes to
maybe supplement some of the lost income
there
because that's just a skill that you
already have like how you think andre
okay yeah that's a really good idea even
my husband who's in production
he'll hire like voice over actors using
some of these gig um higher websites and
so forth and he'd be looking for someone
to just do voiceover work
i definitely agree with andre that
that's something to think about is
leveraging your understanding of like
the voice and voice acting and maybe i'm
seeing if you bring in some additional
income there
me and my fiance erica had
a lot of tough talks and had to scale
down our expectations of
having a wedding trying to plan for the
future and make sure that we're in a
good strong
solid financial place for us that's the
ultimate goal
being able to be in a position to make
choices rather than
sort of make sacrifices and it's funny
you know i was
probably two or three years younger than
you when i was married
we really had to take a hard look at our
our budget
and cutting the cost where we could you
and your wife are fine with
a smaller invite list also consider
maybe an
outside venue also think about music
let's have your own music so those are
just some things to consider
to help with these finances
as it relates to this wedding that
sounds good thank you
leverage your skills and experiences to
generate supplemental income
when budgeting your wedding look for
ways to keep costs at an amount that's
comfortable for you
rachel we are joined by bruno figuerita
so bruno is a better money habits
champion with bank america
and rachel i think that you can do a
better job of really painting the
picture for bruno and letting him know
like
how your personal emergency kind of
kicked off and where you are today
yeah absolutely coronavirus has been
traumatic
for so many people and kind of exposed
what their rainy day funds
look like my personal emergency my rainy
day
happened in january of 2019. i was
rear-ended and it flipped my car over
onto its passenger side
so what i'm really looking forward to
diving in
today with you today is just how i can
balance keeping
myself uh healthy and keeping my bank
account healthy too
my income has been disrupted i don't
have a consistent number
coming in and every single month it
changes
in that inconsistent way how do we plan
for our future
we have freelancing resources to
tracking time budget
taxes and then even moving into a
business aspect and understanding the
difference between an llc and a sole
proprietor
or corporation i always recommend going
back to an account
and finding out if it is right for you
at certain points and i think what's
important to you is based on
your income is inconsistent you still
have to
hate the medical debt yeah yeah a year
ago
my wife was diagnosed with breast cancer
we think
medical debt is a bad thing but it's not
it's a good thing because it's the way
we move
her health forward that's a huge relief
and if i had heard that sentence a year
ago
my recovery probably would have been so
different
okay because that was always in the
forefront of
my recovery even as a financial educator
i have a secret
i'm not debt free i'm still paying off
my student loans you can have
debt and still have a good credit score
as long as you're managing that debt
you had an emergency something happens
first and foremost to me was let me see
if i can bring the bill down at a
different clip
so if they are asking for a hundred
dollars could i call them and say could
we bring this payment down at a
different a minimum amount
in reality they could i just didn't know
that you're carrying a large balance in
your credit card
so maybe you want to take advantage of a
sign-on
account opening bonus or maybe they have
zero percent interest for
12 or 18 months and just transfer a
small amount
of your credit card balance over to that
credit card so that you can pay that
aggressively so that you're not paying
interest towards it i just want to
calculate how much is it going to cost
me to transfer this debt
how much am i going to save an interest
if i transfer this debt
does it make sense for me to do this so
that's something to think about
but you want to be strategic about it
because you don't just want to like
transfer the balance over but end up
paying more money and transfer fees and
you save an interest
i have it's cheesy but it's a
debt calculator so when i spend i
literally
put like a smiley face on the bottom but
the day you hit that minimum or
you got very close to only 20 or 10
percent
you're achieving what you want to do so
i think leveraging our better money
habits website is great
the eight simple ways to save
remembering
make it simple make it realistic analyze
and it's okay to use your savings when
needed thank you for staying me in that
direction i'll definitely
check out that but i'm on habit site as
soon as we're off this call
track your time and budget to help
manage a regular income
as a freelancer research zero percent
interest offers to help pay down a
portion of your debt
it is possible to negotiate with
creditors to adjust your rate
or debt payment plan
so candace this is courtney courtney
pryor she is a
senior vice president over at bank of
america
she is a young adult program manager i
too
am a mom of a young girl who is uh just
gonna be seven
and it's it's a lot it's a lot to manage
yourself
and to manage the well-being of another
you know life
this whole financial journey is so new
to me and i would say within the last
year and a half was when i really dug in
and took it seriously
for my daughter what could i continue to
do that sets her up for success
for us we definitely have a savings
account
that we have established for her and she
knows about it she feels very important
that she has her own bank account
we also have piggy banks that she puts
money into
we started to do a contribution chart
and i
also don't call it a chore chart i call
it a contribution chart
what do you want to do for the house
this week what do you want to do for
yourself this week
those all are ways that kids really
learn by being involved
i need to give my husband a contribution
chart
[Laughter]
nobody has a toolkit for anything right
now
like it's just all learning as we're
going
and i really have found value in some of
what better money habits has to offer
we have tools and resources to help you
prioritize
retirement should be always a part of
your budget plan
because when you retire there's no
supplemental way
to help your retirement unless you want
to get a
job in retirement students can take out
a student loan when you retire
that's like your nest eggs so my wheels
are already turning because i realize
as a parent we think about our kids
first which isn't necessarily a bad
thing but we think about our kids first
before we think about ourselves kind of
like when we fly let's
your oxygen tank on first and then help
others
it's like that same analogy and it's
hard because as a mom you're like oh i
give everything to my baby but
give yourself that gift of security
really the answer is
the more i invest and do things for my
future
truly helps her future contribution
charts and piggy banks are great tools
for teaching children financial literacy
don't neglect your own retirement
savings
yay so we are here it's a new day
we all you guys have all had your
individual 101 sessions we had some
really good conversation
how are you guys feeling about this
entire experience together
learning this stuff and being able to
use it and apply it and then share it
with others
is really like making me excited and it
was nice to taking the taboo out of
talking about finances not being like oh
this is a horrible conversation
be like no this is a conversation that's
going to help us out in the long run and
it's something we should regularly talk
about and look at
yeah he advised us to use an excel sheet
for
our debts and figure out um how much
interest is on each and which ones we
should pay off first
i love that we actually put that
together last night
he was driving you crazy about it you
don't always know what you don't know
and so i am setting up my son's
bank account i can now articulate what
it is that
i need we talked a little bit about the
contribution chart
and being able to do that with my
daughter it's like such a small thing
but i know it will have a huge
lasting impact on our relationship as a
mom and daughter
my action item is look at the skills
that you have now
some of your experience in the past and
see if you can leverage that
to be able to generate some extra income
one of the things we were talking about
before i met in particular was
voiceovers and now listening to him if i
close my eyes i could still hear him on
the radio
i can see it or hear it i can hear it
i need to create a financial team of
people who can advocate for me
bruno is the very first person that i'm
going to add to my
team he talked a lot about making
personal connections with people and
negotiating a rate that's comfortable
for me if my
insurance is too much i need to talk to
a person
um so that i can negotiate that rate
down you're all so different
but you're also committed and so
optimistic i feel rejuvenated
like when i get off of this i'm gonna go
put some more money in my retirement
account i'm so
amped up from you guys better money
habits
offers a simple way to connect people to
relevant
tools and guidance to help them take
control of their finances
go to bettermoneyhabits.com for more
tips
and resources when planning your
financial journey the way to navigate
financial challenges
is to communicate with others about
these challenges
when you're ready to talk go to
bankofamerica.com to schedule time to
speak with a bank of america specialist
thanks to everyone who participated and
thanks for watching
better money habits money talks brought
to you by bank of america